now from the John F Kennedy Library in
Boston Massachusetts
Robert Delic discusses his new biography
and unfinished life John F Kennedy 1917
to 1963 with historian William Lockton
Berg it's an hour and a half good
evening and welcome
I'm Deborah Leff I'm director of the
John F Kennedy Library and Museum and on
behalf of the library and John Shattuck
CEO of the Kennedy Library Foundation
I'd like to welcome you to this
evening's forum looking at the
extraordinary life of President John F
Kennedy as viewed through the new
biography by historian Robert dalek I'd
like to thank our forum co-sponsors
fleet the Lowell Institute in Boston
capital along with our media co-sponsors
WBUR
the Boston Globe and Boston comm the
archives of the John F Kennedy Library
and Museum include 36 million pages of
documents from the collections of 340
individuals organizations and government
agencies oral history interviews with
1300 people and over 30,000 books our
audio-visual archives hold 200,000 still
photographs seven million five hundred
fifty thousand feet of motion picture
film 1200 hours of video recordings over
seven thousand hours of audio recordings
and 500 original editorial cartoons
it appears that Boston University
professor his of history Robert Dalek
has reviewed every one of these items in
piecing together his comprehensive new
biography about President Kennedy and
unfinished life
professor Dalek was the co-winner of the
1980 Bancroft prize for his book
Franklin D Roosevelt and American
foreign policy 1923 through 45 and is
also well known for his to volume set on
President Johnson lone star rising and
flawed giant his distinguished career
includes appointments at Oxford
University and UCLA and he has been
awarded a Guggenheim Fellowship as well
as a senior
fellowship with the National Endowment
for the Humanities joining professor
Dalek on the podium we are delighted to
have as moderator the Dean of American
political history William Lockton Berg I
have to tell you I first had the
pleasure of meeting professor Buckton
Berg some years ago when I was working
with ABC News Nightline and we were
doing a piece on term limits I naturally
turned to the country's leading FBR
scholar to get his perspective and when
I went to visit him professor Luck tibur
groud Lee pulled out his collection of
FDR campaign buttons from 1940 including
the memorable no man is good three times
professor Buckton burg was the William
Rand Kenan professor of history at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill winner of both the Bancroft and the
Parkman prizes he is past president of
the American Historical Association and
the organization of American Historians
he is perhaps best known for his book
Franklin D Roosevelt and the New Deal we
will begin tonight with comments by
Professor Dalek and then a discussion
between professor Dalek and professor
luck Tim Burke and then we'll turn to
audience questions after that I
encourage you to come back and visit our
museum to learn more about the life of
President Kennedy and after the forum
professor Dalek has graciously agreed to
sign copies of his books which are on
sale in our bookstore through that book
the first major biography of President
Kennedy in years we learned so much
about the remarkable life that was and
the life that could have been even more
remarkable were it not an unfinished
life professor Dalek
Debra Debra thank you so much for that
wonderful introduction whenever I get a
nice introduction like that it takes me
back to a time in the Soviet Union the
number of years ago when I was lecturing
there and by hosts on that occasion who
I like to think had an imperfect command
of English introduced me by saying
facade alec is the author of several
distinguished works they're the kinds of
books that once you put them down
you can't pick them up again not the
music to the author's ears I'll try and
talk about some of what I've done in
this book for just the some 20 minutes
so that bill will have a chance and I to
have a conversation what fascinates me
when I began this project was the fact
that the American public sees John F
Kennedy as one of the greatest
presidents in American history last week
the USA Today the newspaper did a poll
asking cross-section Americans to name
the greatest presidents Abraham Lincoln
came in first John F Kennedy was second
in 1990 Americans were asked to rate
president's approval ratings Kennedy
came in number one with an 84 percent
approval rating now historians have
puzzled over this because after all to
suggest that John Kennedy who served but
a thousand days his was the the sixth
shortest presidency in American history
and look at the company in a sense he
kept William Henry Harrison Zachary
Taylor James Garfield Warren Harding
Gerald Ford no one would suggest that
any of them came close to being a great
or even near great president historians
also looking at the Kennedy record point
to his domestic initiatives
not a single one of his major domestic
initiatives passed during his thousand
days in the White House the Medicare
legislation federal aid to education
elementary secondary education the tax
cut none of these came forward he wanted
to have a war on poverty
he spoke about this in his closing days
costs didn't come to pass in his
administration spoke about setting up
departments of Transportation Housing
and Urban Development came later civil
rights didn't pass during his presidency
and historians also say well listen and
farm policy was the man that great after
all think of the Bay of Pigs operation
Mongoose this is also the fellow who
escalated the war in Vietnam expanded
American involvement from six hundred
and fifty advisors to sixteen thousand
seven hundred and then historians cannot
help but look at the fact that there's
been a huge debunking campaign over the
last thirty plus years there I say it
the talk about the womanizing I plead
guilty that there's been so much
discussion of the man's private
transgressions and also historians and
journalists bhaag refers had suspicions
about his his medical problems which
costs have come much more fully to light
since I had access to the medical
records in the last year and a half or
so so in general
historians when asked would not rank him
anywhere near the top of American
presence so the question we have to ask
I asked myself was why does he have such
high standing what accounts for this why
should one think of him or should the
public think of him as such a compelling
presidential figure I think there are a
number of things which account for it
first of all the assassination he was
martyred but one should not forget that
when he McKinley was assassinated in
1901 and 40 years later hardly anybody
remembered him I think television has
been enormous ly important in keeping
his memory alive he's fixed in our minds
at the age of 46 nobody can imagine I
think that at the end of this month he
would have been 86 years of age he
simply fixed there at the age of 46 and
also what television conveys to us is
his charm his wit his intelligence the
press conferences he held so compelling
he was such an attractive man I guess
that much overused word charisma
somebody who reviewed the book in the
Wall Street Journal said clearly
Kennedy's charm can still work its magic
even on as level-headed a historian as
rob italic there's also the fact I think
most importantly maybe that he provided
a kind of hope promise a sense of a
better future to the country there was
something more to the new frontier than
a slogan there was a feeling I think
that America would be a better place the
world would be more peaceful that if he
had lived out his two terms there would
have been a degree of success that would
have changed American history the
ethnics I think ethics are still so held
fast by Kennedy as present by Kennedy
the man because I think he gave ethnics
as the first Catholic president a sense
of acceptance into American life
Roosevelt brought the ethnics into his
administration but Kennedy being
president a Harvard graduate a war hero
a senator then president he made not
just Catholics because I looked at the
voting records and what I found was that
when he ran against law
much for the Senate seat in 1952 it
wasn't just Irish Catholics
it was Italians it was Jews it was poles
it was French Canadians the ethnics
flocked to his banner and I think to
this day there's a kind of a compelling
hold that he has on ethnics in America
the womanizing it hasn't dented his
standing one bit I think here it's a
great deal like Bill Clinton the public
did not want to impeach Bill Clinton
they certainly didn't want to see him
driven from office
they weren't wildly happy about it but
they made the distinction between the
personal and the public between the
private and the presidential action as
far as the medical goes what I think the
public sees is a man of extraordinary
courage that what he shouldered were
these terrible medical difficulties and
he soldiered through them he had a kind
of iron will maybe he was able to
compartmentalize I in looking at the
medical records set them down alongside
of the great crises that he faced as
president and in particular the Cuban
Missile Crisis and what I found was that
he was as lucid as cogent as anyone
would have wished the President to be in
the midst of that that terrible crisis
how he did it is quite impressive if I
had his problems I would have been
cowering in some corner with a cover of
my head
but he chose to be President and he was
really highly effective as far as I'm
concerned is his high standing deserved
in many respects I think it is consider
the domestic side every one of the major
pieces of legislation that Johnson put
across in 64 and 69 not every one but
almost all of them the Medicare the
civil rights bill federal aid to
education the tax cut the department's
of Transportation Housing and Urban
Development the war on poverty they were
all Kennedy initiative
and I think a hundred years from now
historians will look back in the 1960s
and they will see this as the Kennedy
Johnson administration not simply
Johnson's Great Society but I think
they'll give Kennedy credit for the fact
that these bills were on his desk if he
had lived and he ran again in 1964 he
would have won a landslide running
against Barry Goldwater I think he would
have won as big a landslide as Lyndon
Johnson did and he would have carried
into the House and Senate with him the
the large majorities and he would have
put across all those measures foreign
policy here is where he really made I
think an exceptional record his handling
of the Cuban Missile Crisis was
brilliant nothing less than brilliant he
preserved the world from a nuclear war
the test-ban treaty he fought to put
this across
he told Averell Harriman to not send
cables from Moscow that would reach the
Pentagon he only wanted them to come
back to the White House and a very
select group in the State Department he
was very worried that the American
military would undercut this test ban
treaty and he sort of asked them out of
the of the procedure in order to assure
that he would get this this treaty past
Cuba what we see in the last three four
or five months of his presidency were
back-channel discussions initiatives he
knew that his Cuban policy had been
going nowhere and he was intent now on a
possible rapprochement with Castro and
Castro was interested in this too
because the day after the Cuban Missile
Crisis ended he announced to the world
that he was ready for possible talks
with the United States we don't know
nobody can say definitively but if he
had lived I think there is some chance
that we never would have had this kind
of 40 additional years of tension with
with Castro's Cuba
Vietnam here I think was a vital vital
change that occurred when Kennedy was
killed he was so suspicious so
distrustful of the American military in
World War two he wrote letters back to
friends and family in which he spoke
negatively about a number of the naval
offices he saw in the southwest Pacific
and then he was so burned by the Bay of
Pigs operation he felt the CIA and the
military had so to speak taken him into
camp they walked around afterwards
saying how could I have been so stupid
and then this was further deepened his
feeling of doubt by the Cuban Missile
Crisis when the military was pushing him
to bomb Cuba to invade Cuba and he chose
instead to of course rely on a
quarantine and diplomacy and of course
his initiative succeeded and helped the
world avoid a nuclear holocaust seven
days after the Cuban Missile Crisis on
November 5th 1962 he sent Robert
McNamara a memo there was still an
invasion plan for Cuba on the table and
they were worried that Khrushchev might
not follow through on his commitment to
remove the missiles from Cuba Kennedy
said to McNamara Bob the invasion plan
is very thin think of the technical
capacity they have think of the
nationalistic fervor we could meet and
let's not forget what happened to the
British in the Boer War what happened to
the Russians in Finland in 1940 and what
happened to us in North Korea he said we
could get bogged down now this is Cuba
what did he think about Vietnam in 1962
we asked Bob McNamara to begin laying a
plan to withdraw the American advisors
he was worried about Vietnam he didn't
want to see it fall to communism and he
expanded the number of advisors from 652
16700 but this does not mean that he was
eager to or ready to Americanize that
war I find no better evidence for this
than the way in which he was dealing
with the American press corps in Saigon
Lyndon Johnson came to hate the press
corps because they were demoralizing the
war effort he felt Kennedy by contrast
saw the press corps as quite aggressive
about urging a wider more substantial
and more effective role for the United
States and preserving the GM government
in in Saigon they were writing stories
highly critical of American policy of
the failure to assure that South Vietnam
was not going to turn into a communist
country Kennedy was worried that they
could push the Vietnam issue onto the
front pages of the newspapers he asked
that David Halberstam be removed from
Saigon the New York Times of course
wouldn't do it
justifiably understandably but he was
worried that Halberstam in the New York
Times were going to make such an issue
of this that he would feel under
tremendous pressure to expand the war
what he knew of course was if you look
at the Gallup polls in 1961 62 63 there
is not a single Gallup poll I can find
on Vietnam the first Gallup poll I found
was in April of 1964 after the Rolling
Thunder campaign the bombing of Vietnam
had been gun had been started by Johnson
and the public was asked do you know
anything about Vietnam only 37% said
they were paying any attention to
Vietnam a year later in the spring of
1965 after I'm sorry yeah in the spring
of 65 after Johnson was in 65 that he
began the bombing after he'd begun the
bombing spring 65
people were asked what do you think will
be the outcome in Vietnam in in five
years only 22% said they thought they'd
be a pro-american government 45% said
they thought it would either be a
neutralist setup or government or a pro
communist government this is the spring
of 65 in the summer of 65 a majority of
Americans were not intent on a victory
in Vietnam they thought that the outcome
would at best be something like Korea a
kind of stalemate what I'm saying to you
is that if Canada if Kennedy had lived
not only what do you put across I think
those domestic measures that were on his
agenda but I think he would have had the
opportunity to reduce American
involvement in Vietnam and maybe even to
end it please understand me I'm not
saying that John Kennedy having a second
term living out his presidency for eight
years would have brought utopia to
America there would have been problems
other problems there always are problems
but we wouldn't have had Johnson we
wouldn't have had the credibility gap we
wouldn't have had I think the extent to
which we became involved in the Vietnam
War
we wouldn't have had Richard Nixon we
wouldn't have had Watergate and I think
it would have been a much less cynical
in some ways politically alienated
America then the country we now have so
does a man make a difference I think so
does a president count yes in very
important ways
and the tragedy of Kennedy's loss is
that I think we lost a better future
when he was gunned down in in Dallas so
let me stop here and
have bill asked some questions things
one of the things I've admired Bob Shrum
about your career which is you know I
followed from the very beginning oh yes
he examined me before all my walls he
may not remember what we're talking
about is that bob was a graduate student
when I was on the faculty of Columbia
University and I was along with Richard
Hofstadter sponsored his dissertation
which became his first book on William
Dodd the American ambassador under
Franklin Roosevelt to Nazi Germany and
what I was starting to say Bob is that
one of the things I most admired about
your career is what huge subjects you've
chosen to to write about of Franklin
Roosevelt and foreign policy Ronald
Reagan Lyndon Johnson and now John F
Kennedy the fact that you've written
about both Johnson Kennedy it occurs to
me may put you in a somewhat odd
position in that the more you credit
Kennedy with as you having your opening
remarks the the less is the contribution
of the protagonist of your of your
earlier book there is a contrary
position as as you know and nobody is
better qualified than you to deal with
it the the contrary position is that
Kennedy was not a very effective
legislative leader that he had did not
have a remarkable record in the United
States Senate that he was not a skillful
legislative tactician and that if you
look at the record in
the fall just before he was assassinated
each of the programs like civil rights
that the tax cut Medicare they were
bogged down and Kennedy himself as you
say in your wonderful book is deeply
discouraged and the argument is that
required somebody with the skills of
other Lyndon Johnson to put that program
across how would you respond to that Bob
well bill I think I would I don't want
to detract from Johnson's achievement in
the sense that he did enact all those
pieces of legislation and he was a great
legislator who's probably the greatest
majority leader in the in the country's
history but I think the crucial
difference was in that 64 election
because Kennedy as you well know Bill
was up against such a difficult
essentially conservative Congress which
was so resistant to his reform
suggestions or initiatives I think he
did make one great legislative error in
not putting forth a civil rights bill in
61 or 62 he waited till 63 on the
assumption the hope that it would give
him a kind of credential with southern
congressmen senators they would see him
as more accommodating but it didn't
serve him one way because they they
didn't care and if he had put forward a
civil rights bill in 61 or 62 he could
have gone to the country and the
Congress in 63 after all that rioting
and terrible events had occurred in
Alabama and said look I tried to get
this in 61 if we had this maybe we
wouldn't have had all this riding by 63
but I think the crucial difference is
that in the 64 election running against
Goldwater I think he would have won as
big a landslide as Johnson I think he
would have had those big majorities in
the House and Senate and then I think
they would have been receptive to
passing those bills I don't think he
ever would have been
as aggressive as Johnson was about
passing all sorts of other Great Society
measures because Johnson was just
gung-ho to do a million things and
Kennedy was essentially a foreign policy
president and I think he would have been
a much more focused on things like Cuba
and Vietnam and maybe improving
relations with the Soviet Union but
those major Great Society bills like the
ones you just mentioned I think all
would have come to fruition now nobody
can ever prove this but it's I think
reasonable speculation certainly I think
that's a powerful response Kennedy did
not have the kind of majorities and in
either House and Congress that Lyndon
Johnson had after 1964 but if I could
persist just for a moment in 1964 before
Johnson has the advantage of those
majorities as a result of the election
is able to put through the Civil Rights
Act of 1964
certainly one of the half-dozen most
important pieces of legislation in all
of our history the tax cut and the war
on poverty is without without that so
well anything there bill I think what he
did have was Kennedy's death and he was
able and I tracked Johnson's speeches
and what I was struck by was the extent
to which before the 64 election he
constantly invokes John Kennedy's name
and he's appealing to the public and to
the Congress in terms of his model them
once he's elected his own right he wants
to push Kennedy so to speak off the
radar screen because he as you know he
doesn't want Bobby Kennedy is running
mate Bobby Kennedy are loggers head
would put it politely but he was going
to be present in his own right he was
not going to be seen as in JFK's shadow
but he was a very shrewd politician and
he understood how powerful an initiative
this was to talk about you've got to do
what the modern president would have
wanted and but of course it also got him
in trouble because on Vietnam he said he
was doing what the moderate president
wanted and there I think he was off on
the wrong track well I certainly think
you're right on folks points both in his
very first address to the new Congress
of Lyndon Johnson asked the Congress to
enact a civil rights bill as a tribute
as it as a memorial to John F Kennedy
and on your other point I can give a
personal testimony in September 1965 I
was invited by the Johnson White House
to conduct an interview with him and
normally have maybe 10 or 15 minutes
with a president I have about an hour
and a half and he was totally indiscreet
and when when I when I walked out I
built awareness was then his press
secretary and I said to of to Bill's
assistant that you don't need to tell me
I can't use 90% of this and the men
replied better make it 95%
especially about John Kennedy bill that
I fellas not telling you that he
published this as an article in American
heritage it's a wonderful article so
revealing about Lyndon Johnson and at
the end of the article what bill said
was watching Johnson I felt like I had
watched somebody defecate on the
presidency remember that line Johnson
was not a very refined fellow
I was astonishing abuse if he was to
Kennedy's memory and in some ways to you
as well because he saw yours as a
liberal who he was going to beat up on
you're an author shlessinger type of
record you right right yes he said I'm
not like you people like Schlesinger who
think all senators we've got gravy down
this another series let's follow up on
on the Vietnam comparison that you've
just alluded to again Bob because as you
know there's also a contrary arguments
there the one strong argument you've
already acknowledged that the
acceleration in Vietnam begins none of
the Johnson but under Kennedy though of
course not
to the dimensions of the hundreds of
thousands of troops that eventually
would be there but from the point of
view of Johnson and indeed from the
point of view of some of the Johnson
scholars now who look on him somewhat
more sympathetically it was Kennedy who
gave Johnson a legacy in Vietnam that
was hard for him the GAO from under you
were mentioning that you don't see a
poll about Vietnam until sometime in
1964 by that same measure it's arguable
that it was kennedy who put it on the
front burner that it was he who
could have a walk away from that issue
and finally that the people who were the
architects of the expansion of the war
in Vietnam are dearest
Rostow of bundy and bob mcnamara or
their 1080 people yep so that it's it's
been an uphill argument to say that the
Kennedy people around Johnson would have
of what would have agree with
withdrawing well don't my thought about
this and number of people asked me well
what about the fact that these were the
same advisers and they were pushing the
envelope in terms of Vietnam Bob nemac
McNair himself and Mack Bundy both of
whom I spoken to about some of these
matters over time
Bowden said that they think Johnson a
different man different time acted that
they can see that he acted differently
from from Kennedy and also I'm of a mind
to think that in some ways these
advisers are sort of chameleons on plaid
and they take their impulse from the the
president they're dealing with see
Kennedy was an independent-minded fellow
and I think that that people like
McNamara when you know Kennedy ordered
him to make a plan to get out of Vietnam
he didn't come back to Kennedy to say oh
you're making a big mistake this is
wrong it's he conformed to what the
president was telling him to do I think
the great difference between Kennedy and
Johnson here is the fact that Kennedy
going to a second term had political
credibility had credentials that Johnson
simply lacked he had the two Missile
Crisis behind him he had the test ban
treaty he had standing as a foreign
policy president to a degree that he
certainly didn't have as domestic exec
or president and I think he could have
managed a kind of stand down from
Vietnam in a way that Lyndon Johnson
couldn't because Johnson was so on edge
and talked about the possibility that if
he leaves Vietnam the Communists could
see him as weak as a kind of nervous
Nellie that he's going to be getting out
and he's got to show them that he's
standing up to them and Kennedy didn't
have to do that it was a very different
sort of perspective for him and I think
the public would have seen him in a in a
very different way then they they saw
Johnson and so again we can't say nobody
can ever say definitively but I I think
it's reasonable speculation to think
that his credentials is standing in
foreign policy would have given him the
leeway to to shift ground I'm sure that
you're going to be on talk shows all
over America and the and in the coming
weeks and I was so fascinated by your
opening remarks that I've led off but
with these questions instead of asking
you the the unavoidable question that
every talk show host in America will
lead off with why another book on
Kennedy's I've given all of the books
that have already been written including
overall judicious books her poor mad
people like that how would you respond
to that
how will you be responding to it well
for how have have I been responded to it
because I've been on thanks to Clem okay
yeah a million of these talk shows
already and a lot of them asked just
this just this question um what I say is
that presidential history especially
modern recent presidents like Kennedy
like Johnson Richard Nixon it's the
frontier scholarship
thanks to Deborah Leff a lot of material
is opening up this Kennedy Library I had
confidence
that there would be new interesting
material national security files oral
histories maybe the medical records I
didn't know that I'd get into them but I
was hopeful and I was not disappointed
because for example the the McNamara
memo from Kennedy to McNamara I've never
seen that cited or quoted by by anybody
else I also found out about Joe Kennedy
jr. how was he killed in in the second
world war an English member of British
member of the royal mechanical
electrical engineers a sent a letter to
the library about a year and a half ago
in which he said that I was there I saw
the Kennedy plane go down and he
explained the reason it went down was
because the American air forces forgot
to tell British radar to turn off their
radars it triggered the electrical
mechanism on the plane and blew it up
and killed so it was a kind of friendly
fire
I found a memo about Robert Kennedy the
whole idea that Robert Kennedy was eager
not to serve in his brothers
administration I think that's nonsense
I think Robert Kennedy was going to be
there in the administration in one major
capacity or another and what did I find
on December 15th the traditional story
goes Robert Kennedy calls up jack and he
says Tim Jack I don't want to do it jack
system come to the Georgetown house
tomorrow morning our breakfast and we'll
will we'll work this out Bobby goes
there the next morning and brings with
him John Seigenthaler the journalist why
in the world would he bring a Tennessean
or remember this Tennessee press corps
and a friend is to a private meeting
like this well they wanted to put out a
story a kind of fiction they were going
to spin they were nervous about the fact
that the New York Times had picked up on
a discussion that Bobby Kennedy might
become Attorney General and they said
this is outrageous he's not suited
doesn't have the experience the
background and then the Kennedys put out
the idea that Bobby didn't want to do it
and Joe the father was insisting that
Bobby do it
and so you find a memo in the papers
from Bobby Kennedy to Drew Pearson dated
December 15 and he says the piss and
drew Jack and I have decided I'm going
to do it this is the day supposed to
call Jack up and tell him oh I don't
want to do it and they'll have this
breakfast meeting the next morning and I
have the meeting and perform this dance
in front of a singing fuller who then
writes up the idea that Wow Bobby
Kennedy had to be dragged kicking and
screaming into this and Jack says to him
don't smile when we go out to see the
press we don't want to think you're
happy and you know this is the sort of
invention of well that was yet another
thing I found and so it was so you know
Bill you do this guy learned from you to
do this guiding research you go into the
archives and you look at these papers
interviews yeah but those papers are
essential so I found it very exciting
and then finally I'd say that the famous
comment of the Duchess story Peter Hale
history is argument without end and look
we're already talking about different
perspectives and people say to be all
wonderful this may be a definitive book
and I say oh there's no such thing ten
years now somebody else is going to be
writing as the well they showed a big
biography of JFK and of course 40 years
down the road the Jacqueline Kennedy
oral history of 500 pages is going to be
opened and who knows what's there so
there will be plenty of books in the
future and it's just we keep doing it
besides with compulsive fellows we got
to do something
the fine ass do something else
next Bob with your reference to
Jacqueline Kennedy reminds me of a
different train of thought when
Jacqueline Kennedy died I was on CBS
television much of the day with the
Paula Zahn and Harry Smith in the
morning and I was at the anchor desk
with the Dan Rather in the afternoon and
I was struck afterwards about how many
women came up
to me and said how important Jacqueline
Kennedy Onassis was to them as loose as
a role model and on another television
program I was on with Michael Beschloss
he said that that she played a larger
role in policy than is generally
believed of in assessing the Kennedy
presidency of what kind if any role does
a Jacqueline Kennedy I feel I did not
find her fingerprints so to speak on the
policy making I did not find that he was
consulting her about the Cuban Missile
Crisis so now maybe there was a
discussion that was very private but I
did not find that evidence what I think
though is quite compelling is the fact
that so many women or people came up to
you and remarked on her importance to
them and that I think is quite
understandable because I think what
she's remembered for is her
extraordinary dignity in the face of the
terrible tragedy of her husband's
assassination and what a wonderful
mother she was and how effective she was
with her two children and how sensible a
person she was and how much dignity she
gave to the White House the redecoration
of the White House her behavior when
they went to Paris France and and the
goal was so taken with her and also one
must say she shouldered a great painful
burden you know as mrs. Johnson did as I
guess Hillary Clinton has this surely is
not easy on these women it must be a
very painful and difficult business and
yet she comes across I think and
deserves to come across to us as someone
with great dignity and and really maybe
in many ways the model of what a first
lady
should be you were talking about the
burden that she showed and I'm sure
you're referring to all of Kennedy's
relationships with other women and yes
this is your point but yes on as my wife
Jean and I were driving up today we
stopped for a breakfast in Stonington
Connecticut and after breakfast we went
to the rear of the restaurant and the
men's room there is labeled Abby Clinton
and the ladies room there is is labeled
M Lewinsky and when at the end of this
just in a small small restaurant in the
Seacoast town when the Clinton
presidency we was coming to an end
the Boston Globe called me in North
Carolina and among other things I said
that the Lewinsky affair and the ensuing
impeachment Clinton being the only
elected president in our history of it
who have been impeached is going to be
in the first paragraph of every obituary
now nobody would ever say this about
John F Kennedy and yet as your book
brings out the the transgressions of
John F Kennedy who were infinitely
greater than those of Bill Clinton how
do you counter that yes well-built I
have 38 words two lines in the book
about the famous intern and how did I
get to this Barbra gamma Rickey in who
was
in the press office of the Kennedy White
House with the PS Salinger
she had an oral history 17 pages were
blacked out my historians curiosity said
gosh what could be here I went to her
she lives in Washington and she said all
rights forty years later all open to you
and lo and behold there's this material
about the intern now it was fascinating
because the connection to Bill Clinton
was so striking to me and particularly
this question that you've asked me how
could it have been that John Kennedy
carries on this way and Bill Clinton
gets caught out so to speak and is
embarrassed and is impeached and this
doesn't come forward as something which
jeopardized this presidency I think the
answer is that it was a very different
political and media culture in the 1960
s I spoke to a number of journalists who
said to me they knew about mr. Kennedy's
womanizing and if they didn't know about
it they strongly suspected it but they
were not aggressive about pursuing it
and what Kennedy understood was that
this was something at the time which was
largely out of bounds there was a
right-wing press that did talk about his
womanizing but as Kennedy himself once
said it's not news until it's on the
front page of the New York Times well
even if we're in some of the other
mainstream press on page 10 or something
but they didn't pursue it they didn't do
it
and of course Gary Hart says follow me
and the press has been ever since and of
course it's a changed world with all
these cable channels and Murdoch comes
into our media culture and tabloid
journalism and I guess also I'm a bit
naive I put these two lines in the book
Dateline which interviewed me almost two
weeks ago now they ran a story on a
Sunday and that afternoon a guy from the
New York Daily News calls me up and he
says I want to talk to you about the
intern I said how do you know about this
he said because they twine has put this
out as a press release and so you asked
me a couple of questions and I naively
said to him you're going to run a story
about this he said man he
we can put it on the front page says
Kennedy's Monica and on page three is
not only a story but a picture of me and
Monica what did I let myself in for to
my great joy my daughter called us up on
Sunday and she said then she said this
fellow what's his name Goldstein who is
the editor of New York times.com and he
was on a local NBC station in New York
City speaking and he said I want to tell
you about this Kennedy book now this
fella dalek it's amazing he revealed
this stuff about medical history about
the intern this guy's a professor you
couldn't meet somebody who was more
prophets loriel emphasizing that and I
was very gratified because I don't want
to be known as I was scandal longer it's
but I think essentially it's a change in
the culture and of course I hold no
brief for what can we did I mean it's
said and in some ways it's shocking and
one has to ask what was there about the
man that he had to engage in this sort
of behavior a 19 year old he's president
for the United States it's so
distressing to think and Bill Clinton
but he should have known better in the
sense that the media by this point was
on everybody's case and so a different
world different time I think is the
answer if it's any satisfaction to you
Bob this can happen to you even if you
haven't written a word about it some
years ago I was reviewing in a very long
book by Jonathan Daniels which had a
small passage in it about Franklin
Roosevelt's relationship to Lucy Mercer
and I wasn't sure it was credible how
wrong I was
but beyond that it was in the few words
I had are hardly worth mentioning but
the New York Times broke the story on
the front page just has happened
happened to you and then they did
something that never happened to me in
my life
before or since they inserted a sentence
about Lucy Mercer in my review that they
printed in the subsequent Sunday New
York Times
so that's how eager but the press
sometimes is to to grab bits of this
sort elec file I'm sorry I'm a justice
man from brief an active in the negative
times Metro section on the Wednesday
after all this stuff came out pointed
out to me that there was a little squib
about a New York Times journalist who
was attending some social functions
celebrating another New York Times
journalist and Bill Clinton was there
and she left the Clinton and she said oh
nice to see you he said Oh lovely to see
you and she said to me have you seen or
read this new book by Robert Alec on
Kennedy he said oh I know
Daleks with wonderful books on Lyndon
Johnson just splendid
she said yeah but you have read the
Kennedy book no no I haven't read that
yet and then she said to make small talk
she said have you read Robert Carol and
he said oh yeah terrific books on
Johnson wonderful work and she said but
Gavin read Alec on Kennedy he said no I
gotta go now and so we could I think one
of the things that we least want to do
is spend a lot of time on on something
that is being talked about only for its
sensationalist aspects and I know that
anybody reads your book knows what a
small part that particular episode plays
but there is just one other question on
on on this in this area because isn't
there something more significant here
the than the single episode
of the the intern you are quote a good
number of Jack Kennedy's letters as a
teenager and as a college student which
I found truly shocking the way in which
he treats women the demeaning way he he
treats women he says at one point that I
want to separate one out of out of the
herd of cattle on and Brander
for example isn't there a further
problem of his having a liaison with the
woman with mafia connections isn't there
a further problem with as having a
liaison with with a woman who was a
security risk and then finally isn't
there a problem in our assessment of the
Kennedy presidency in that because as we
were saying earlier the legislative
record is so thin so much of his
reputation rests on style and the aura
that was cast about this wonderful
marriage in the White House with the
with the young children when you set the
sexual behavior against that then isn't
it a legitimate subject for historians
to be concerned with Bill I think when I
wrote this book I included all the
incidents you mentioned because it seems
to me you cannot write a book about John
Kennedy's life at this point
and exclude those letters exclude that
material because there was something
off-center about the man's behavior and
I tried to understand it I think in some
ways he learned it as father's knee I
think he also modeled himself after
British aristocrats who had
impulse toward this kind of modernizing
as well I think he was also driven by
this feeling that his older brother died
his younger sister Kathleen died it was
going to be a short life he had all
sorts of medical problems and he was
living it to the fullest but still that
does not explain what you are describing
which really was a very abusive approach
one might say and also abusive to his
wife because I mean it was ugly the
kinds of things that have been described
about what he did being at a party with
her and walking out with some young
woman I mean gosh it really is Darce
Kearns Goodwin reveal that years ago in
the Fitzgerald's and Kennedys and I find
that and I have that one episode in my
book in which he's on the campaign trail
he goes into a hotel he nudges one of
his aides and points to one of the
pom-pom girls there and the guy goes up
to her and says the senator would like
to see you in his room and the story is
that she goes up to the room and she
walks in he looks as watch and says well
we have 15 minutes and then what
happened after that I have no idea but
but but it is so striking that he was a
kind of I don't know how you would quite
describe it except maybe abusive and
sure it's it's it's relevant it's
certainly a part of the man's history in
a part of the story and it's a fixed
college story that those four Secret
Service agents gave a seymour hersh that
the material and I trust that they were
speaking the truth the other aspect of
your book that depresses made a great
deal of is you're discovering new
medical records and you deal with that
in the considerable detail and it
certainly detailed none of us has ever
known about before I'm reminded of a
book that came out a generation ago when
I think about the time I think that I
first encountered you Bob a a book
appeared suggesting that a certain
American president had an unnatural
relationship to his sister and my
colleague David Donald the one of
America's four great historians and
biographers my colleague done it at
Columbia said well that's all very
interesting but I want to know what this
tells us about the bland Ellison Act
meaning the leading currency issue of
the day and this is a similar kind of
question here after one has found all of
this evidence about this a you alluded
to it briefly in your opening remarks
how does it affect our understanding of
his policies of the way he behaved as as
chief executive well I think that both
with the womanizing and with the medical
history the fundamental question that
the historian the biographer has to ask
did it have any impact on his conduct of
the presidency that's the most important
part of it what impact did it have on
making policy toward Vietnam Civil
Rights the other domestic initiatives
the Cuban Missile Crisis the medical was
much more important to me because
tracking down how the womanizing might
have deterred him from carrying on or
dealing with the domestic and foreign
policy I think maybe rich Greaves put it
best in his volume President Kennedy
when she said the womanizing took him no
more time than to arrange a tennis match
maybe that's too flippant but on the
other hand I could not see clear
evidence that there was a deterrence to
behaving in thoughtful considered ways
about major issues on the medical which
it was such a constant struggle to deal
with day in and day out and we had my
medical colleague and I who reviewed the
records we had something : MA or
medicine administration record and we
could set these down alongside for
example of the Cuban Missile Crisis and
track day by day the medicines he was
taking the fact that they increased the
hydrocortisone he took and the salt
tablets in order to deal with the
pressures the tensions that he was under
because his Madisonian his adrenal
glands don't function and he needs this
to keep him steady and going effectively
what my medical friend Jeff Kelman told
me was that if it were not the medicines
he probably could not have performed
effectively as president he could not
have carried off his performance in that
Cuban Missile Crisis
now when he went into the privacy of his
quarters at night maybe he was a bit
zonked maybe he was
driven in one direction or the other by
the medicine but I tried to set the
medical records down alongside of the
various crises over Berlin the Bay of
Pigs / Alabama the Civil Rights did it
did he seem less than lucid less than
cogent and of course we have the tapes
the tapes are so revealing and so
helpful in tracking his performance and
what he does and I found him
consistently cogent then and he did have
a kind of iron will I think - a kind of
strength of character - but bill I share
with you the feeling which I think you
probably have this was something which
we would never want to do again he was
making a big that he could perform
effectively as president I think all of
us are entitled to the privacy of our
medical records but when it comes to
presidents I think we're entitled to
know as much as we possibly can about
their physical and emotional health they
have their fingers on the nuclear
trigger this is something which I don't
think should be sacrosanct and of course
they hide their medical histories we
know going back to Grover Cleveland he
hit it Woodrow Wilson hit it FDR in 1944
Roosevelt didn't want to know but
nevertheless as we know
Churchill's position that the yatha said
the president has hardening of the
arteries of the brain he'll be dead in
three months time and he called it right
on the mark so I don't think that his
hiding this and it was a cover-up is
just I think that term is an appropriate
description of what they did about his
medical problems and it continued after
his death because I heard from
physicians and others who knew about
what was going on how records were
destroyed his urologist a man by the
name of Hearst was approached by the FBI
and asked to turn over the the
urological records they said I have to
consult the family he did Bobby Kennedy
told him destroy the records which he
did a young man at the time in the White
House is a
tablo berkeley physician named young
tells me he believes that the berkeley
medical records were destroyed at Bobby
Kennedy's behest so there was a cover-up
we wouldn't want to do that again
happily I think Kelly was able to carry
it off but it's it's a cautionary tale I
can ask for one more question
before opening the floor to questions
you'll see that there are microphones
Department in in each aisle here and if
you have questions for Bob if you would
line up in in order behind the the
microphones I would appreciate it this
is this is my last question Bob and I've
enjoyed this immensely of the the you
mentioned in your book that one of the
two figures most responsible for
handling the transition between a
Kennedy's election and his taking office
was the Columbia political scientist
dick Neustadt and I recall that when you
start returned from one of these
meetings with the president-elect
Kennedy we had lunch at the Columbia
faculty Club and he said to me the
Kennedy presidency will bring many
things but the New Jerusalem will not be
one of them and after Kennedy died when
you start who was certainly well
disposed toward Kennedy was asked about
him he said I think that that John F
Kennedy will only be a flicker
that he will be lost in the parade of
other presidents that history Neustadt
said will not have much space for John F
Kennedy now how do you respond to Bill
I've thought of that because thickness
that said the same thing to me we once
spoke about this and he said exactly
this that one hundred two hundred years
it's hard to imagine that Kennedy will
hold some kind of significant place in
the country's history
I'd be more optimistic about this bill I
think getting back to your point about
style style and substance are not
entirely divorced and given the kinds of
presidents we've been seeing
I said enough for first you realize
about what I've just been inviting you
to do is to say about the book on which
you spent so many years and which you
are about to promote around the country
is about a figure of minor estar I'm
surprised by your response the fourth
element questions not going to move I'll
buy I'll so that there isn't any
disadvantage to being in any particular
oil and I'll start with my my left let
me just say as a ground rule no speeches
please make your questions to Professor
delicas 16th this vigil is about three
months ago I was in this room when we
when we discussed the Nixon tapes and at
that time we had a very distinguished
panel of people historians scholars
writers and I asked the question
touching on Vietnam that you dealt with
and I asked whether they thought that
Kennedy would have accelerated the
number of troops in Vietnam none of them
had an answer none of them knew and yet
you come up with a analysis saying that
even though he went from 650 to 16700
that he would have been in essence in my
words backed off at some point I have
not read this anywhere these scholars
did not know what is your evidence for
that well first of all unlike them I
wrote an 800-page book on John Kennedy
and I spent a lot of time reading
studying thinking about this and I think
if you read an article I have in the
current issue of the Atlantic Monthly
June issue I lay out there the major
pieces of evidence that I think support
this proposition that I think he would
have been very dubious about
Americanizing the war in Vietnam I don't
deny for a minute there was an increased
involvement on his part
he was concerned the Green Berets were
part of his this operation but the
Americanization of the war to the extent
that Lyndon Johnson engaged in it was
just something that I do not believe
John Kennedy ever would have committed
to the course of everything I read about
his view of the military about his view
of being bogged down in Cuba being drawn
into a morass in Vietnam Maxwell Taylor
his chairman of Joint Chiefs of Staff
said that Kennedy had a visceral
aversion to putting ground troops that
is combat troops into Vietnam and
Kennedy himself said this is not like
Korea Korea was a direct act of
aggression and he spoke about how
different this was from Korea and how if
we got involved in such a conflict it
could open up a painful breach in the
United States among the public as to
what we were doing there so I can only
say I can't recount all the evidence I
have in my book but I think it's I think
it's a fairly compelling case and that's
what I would argue my name is Michael
yovanovich and I'm serving I've been to
many shorts in my mugs because I'm
serving I cannot be objective and
subjective because Serbian people like
Jeff Kennedy more than any other nation
in the world was witnessing for the 1964
that every single family had john f
kennedy's picture and one of the
communist leaders told me then when he
died serbian people grieve so much as
the grief and king of Yugoslavia was
killed who spoke about domestic and
foreign policy in his inaugural speech
kennedy said my fellow Americans ask not
what America can do for you ask what you
can do for your country
this was capsulated for a formula for
his domestic policy in the next sentence
he capsulated his foreign-policy to
remember what was the next sentence you
tell me my memory I'm a historian I
forget okay I remind you next sentence
was my fellow citizens of the world ask
not what America can do for you ask for
together can do for the freedom of man
sir you're being very eloquent
now can you phrase frame a question okay
that was formulation okay on me me I
would like to make a remark Romans had a
saying then the multiple Snickle Missy
Benny I bought the debt nothing but but
good well Susan Ethan came to Harvard he
criticized American motto people have
the right to know he said people have
the right not to know every president is
a role model what was the reason that
you have in your book to say something
that does not contribute to the great of
the greatest American president some
people think that you wanted to
publicize your book I would like to
defend you how could I defend something
that you should not have done well I
think Bill lockberg put it very well
previously this is a part of the his
womanizing is part of the historical
record and after don't hear you could
you come closer this is a this is a part
of the historical record and after the
Bill Clinton experience I think this is
a historical fact about the intern which
is not necessarily salacious especially
if you're putting in just two lines
about it I did not know the woman's name
I did not try and find out who she was I
had no intention or desire to embarrass
her
was one of the newspapers that brought
this forward and she said she's relieved
now that it's out in the open but my
feeling is that it is a historical fact
and it shall be there I'm sorry I can
tell you have believed me
no no no no we cannot have colloquy you
are out of order look what happened
you're out on your otherwise my sons
have played Kennedy's challenge to all
of us to become citizens of the world is
really what motivates my question how
would you describe Kennedy's vision of
the United Nations at that time in
history and also then how would you
describe Kennedy's vision of
multilateralism within his foreign
policy at that time a wonderful question
I think that he understood that America
was not able to go it alone in the world
he went to Canada he did not like the
Prime Minister of Canada he said some
unkind things about him in private he
was not wildly happy about Charles de
Gaulle he had all sorts of tensions with
with Khrushchev but he understood that
the United States lived in a very
dangerous world that allies were
essential to our national well-being and
to the future peace of the world and as
Winston Churchill once said the only
thing worse than having allies is not
having them and he was committed to
building these relationships and also he
was profoundly concerned about the third
world about Africa a friend of mine Phil
Kaiser was his ambassador to Senegal and
Phil tells me that he was so concerned
to assure a kind of victory for hearts
and minds in Africa he raised the
consciousness of at least people in his
administration over matters relating to
Africa I don't want to you know
glamorize it as to suggest that he you
know took phenomenal initiatives but it
was important to him and the world and
and he was a foreign policy president he
travelled this was what he knew much
more than knowing about civil rights
knowing about the plight of
african-americans in this country he was
much more attuned to questions of war
and peace and having good relations with
allies I follow to questions well
actually two remarks this I want to say
is this a Sheldon Stern who spent more
years at this library and then I ever
did and he's bringing out a wonderful
book on the Cuban Missile Crisis with
Stanford University Press and the next
month Shulman yeah thank you very much
saying that two points one I wanted to
agree or just give you another argument
for the Vietnam question and that is
that for those who say that McNamara
Bundy rasca cetera world Kevin Kennedy
people they should all listen to the
Saturday October 27th meetings when he
stood up against every one of them and
said and did not do what they wanted him
to do so I mean I think that's an
extremely important point if there had
been a vote that day he would have been
just about the only one to vote no yes
and they all voted no and like that
famous Lincoln it but the Lincoln
himself precisely okay then the other
thing which I wanted to disagree with
you is I think that which you said twice
that Kennedy would have won in 64 by
this by a similar margin the terms of
Johnson's victory I don't think that's
the case I think he would have lost much
of the South George Wallace in his
interview here at the library makes that
point and I think he was quite right
that they would have carried many
southern states against mafic Barry
Goldwater himself said that he knew he
had a chance against Kennedy and as soon
as you heard Kennedy had been killed he
said there's no point in running because
I can never be Johnson but you ran
anyway but that's
except Sheldon I think he would have
certainly kept Johnson on the ticket
because of just the point you're making
his sensitivity to winning some of those
southern states and of course that's
what Johnson gave him in 1960 gave him
Texas and a handful of southern states
which were crucial in allowing up to the
difference of a civil rights between the
four earrings are sure sure that that
had become a hot issue and it was but
there's some wonderful material I came
across from some people in the South who
were writing and especially I think
middle-class southerners who wanted to
free the south from the burden of
segregation the burden of apartheid and
I it's hard to know and I think you know
your argument is is well taken but but
whether he would have lost that much of
the south I'm not sure but he still
would have won a very big factory one of
the big biggest victories I think
presidential history thank you darling
we're all struck by venez now Kennedy's
charisma and personal style it was so
affable and magnetic I'm curious were
there particular nuggets particularly
things that you on earth in your
research that you hadn't previously
known that were new and exciting for you
limit with that fed into that charisma
it could be anything from like a
rhetorical tool he used or a something
sort of specific that you unearthed that
you found interesting and compelling
well I think the most striking aspect
for me there was reading the medical
records and as bill said the extent of
his illnesses simply were not knowing
seeing that he was hospitalized nine
times between 1955 and 57 once the 19
days twice for a week and I was just
taken aback by the extent of his medical
problems and all the medications he took
and how he was able to function I just
marvel did this and then to have the
audacity to run for president
and that he's doing this when he's
hospitalized and the public doesn't know
it nine times he's revving up to run a
presidential campaign now maybe this is
foolishness audacity but the guy had a
kind of determination the iron will that
I found very impressive and so made me
feel all the sympathetic to him and see
him I guess is more of a charismatic and
the appealing Fagan yes could you talk a
little bit about after the Johnson
election in 64 his decision to keep most
of the Kennedy cabinet together I think
that's a big part of that story it
you've written two books on this and
there's that's a key transition and you
hear about it you people talk about it
but can you really get into that and how
that helped Johnson and how it hurt him
well you see I think it's speaks volumes
about Lyndon Johnson's psychology he
wanted to be President in his own right
but what he wanted so badly was for the
Kennedy people to accept his legitimacy
as president to win after the
assassination when they're on Air Force
One about to go back to Washington he
takes the oath of office he didn't have
to take an oath of office under the
Constitution as I understand it the
minute the president was killed the vice
president became president now he did
this as a ceremonial and he insisted
that Jacqueline Kennedy come forward
some people have seen this as rather
cruel because there she was standing
with her blood-spattered suit on and he
wanted her there as a sign of his
legitimacy he was a brilliant politician
very sensitive to these political
nuances and I think he wanted the
cabinet he told people like author
shlessinger and he's told Bobby Kennedy
that I need you now more than your
brother needed you see because he knew
that there was also going to be
speculation that he might have had a
hand in doing Kennedy in and of course
this the foot of the flames of this sort
of Ninh fan by Oliver Stone in his very
foolish movie JFK
and and and I think I think he was I was
thinking he was deeply worried by this
and so and there were people around him
like John Connelly who told him you know
get rid of these fellows they're not
your they're not your folks and slowly
but surely number of them did drift away
like Mack Bentley Schlesinger left very
quickly Sorensen left but the PS
Salinger left but I think he saw it as
an essential ingredient of giving him a
kind of legitimacy Johnson instantly
called Pierre Salinger pierre-joseph
blue mind I have some fascination things
here I like to check out with you ever
since I 1840 in increments of 20 years
has either been a death or an
assassination in the presidency it which
went up to even Ronald Reagan which
survived the assassination I don't know
about George Bush but he was elected in
2000 and then it says uh both uh both
Lincoln and Kennedy went to Congress in
1846 is that correct
Oh Lincoln with a grade 46 and 46 yeah
agent well III excuse me got it
Lincoln went in 1846 and Kennedy in 1946
are you familiar with these increments
yeah I've heard this before and I don't
know what to make of them oh that's
right here free that's right not like
God it was uh you know Lincoln in 1860
Kennedy in 1960 I both had civil rights
out both were shot on Friday both shot
in the back of the head their wives are
linking the Secretary Kennedy Lincoln
both with southerners okay I think I
think we're going to have to cut cut it
because that we're running out of time
and I can see it's something different
and my answer is don't run for president
and those even years
I showed you actually Kennedy was aware
of that 20 year and it's described in
his physician Janet travels a book about
Kennedy and he said he she says tells
him this and he said she says you don't
believe in anything like this happening
to you and research isn't doubt
unless there's the kind of melodramatic
aspect of this yes I'd like to go back
to the this is Martin showing who's
professor of history and the Tufts
University and a nose dissertation
adviser was bought a light and therefore
I'm related to Bill Upton burg by once
removed my grandfather I'd like to go
back to the big counterfactual of if
Kennedy had lived what would have
happened in Vietnam for almost 20 years
in all my lectures I always argued the
opposite of what you've argued in your
in your book and I began to change my
mind in the mid-1980s when was revealed
by Dean Rusk that he had been called
into Kennedy's office on what the 27th I
think it was and told to arrange a
meeting should things not work out
between Andrew Cordier I think at
Columbia and Bhutan secretary-general
United Nations who was then to announce
a trade between the missiles in Turkey
and the missiles in Cuba to avoid what
the military had committed itself to and
this is a question really about the
character and decision-making John
Kennedy took I think the most difficult
decision
that I know of any president ever taking
when he refused to commit the American
military during the Bay of Pigs - a
follow-up he was three months in office
and it was an extraordinary act of
political courage and potentially
political suicide this man had a sense
as you pointed out in your book in the
article in your in your talk of a the
limitations of military power and I'm
really sort of following up on your
question not only is there all of this
evidence that Professor dalek as you
know reveal but there is character there
and I think that the the most profound
support for the argument are the Bay of
Pigs decision the Cuban Missile Crisis
decision which shows how in these deep
deep commitments and crises he was
different than Nixon he was different
than Johnson and he was somebody who
would not have gotten us involved and I
guess since we have to put this as a
matter of a question do you agree Marty
you know what they say great minds think
alike
I would just add to that the wonderful
tape which Sheldon of course and I both
have listened to and know about Kennedy
talking about to two or three of his
aides about the American military and he
says you know these fellas in the
Foreign Service
they have no cojones now these guys in
the military they have cojones but there
have any brains and I think it goes
echoes your point this is Bruce Schulman
professor of history my colleague at
Boston University say we're stacking the
year Bob I want to ask you also about
the great counterfactual but not with
regard to Vietnam that is in imagining a
second Kennedy term one which you have
to admit is much more successful than
the actual Kennedy term on record you've
resolved one of the two great divisive
wounds of the 60s the Vietnam War the
other of course is race and particularly
the more than a hundred urban race riots
major violent incidents that take place
every summer from 1965 to 1968 now is
there anything in the record that you've
seen that suggests that Kennedy would
have been able to negotiate that crisis
differently or better than Johnson that
he might have been able to keep the
Democratic Party coalition together over
that or how would you think Cruz I think
it's an excellent question an excellent
point I think these are one of the
problems that Kennedy would have
shouldered in a in a second term I don't
think we would have I mean some people
to speculate that Johnson raised such
hopes that those ghettos exploded out of
a kind of frustration but I think it's a
much more complicated situation and I
doubt that the Kennedy would have had
great answers or different answers or
better answers than the Lyndon Johnson
that was not his area so to speak of
expertise or keen understanding he
didn't know african-americans this was
not part of his world he was really
divorced from that and as I said before
I think it's insensitivity to all this
was demonstrated by the fact that he
does not put forward Civil Rights Act
and 61 or 62 and he's dragged into it so
to speak in 63 the speech he makes is a
great speech because he's finally giving
a kind of recognition to what I think he
should have recognized earlier and I do
give him credit while learning on the
job
so to speak but I think this would have
been something that would have playing
him in a second term and would have been
a real difficulty for him yes you
mentioned Kennedy's appeal to ethnics
which was perhaps the origin of American
multiculturalism I don't know but there
is another interest currently which is
American imperialism and your colleague
Andrew bacevich has written a book on
the American Empire which he's opposed
to and I'm reading Niall Ferguson's book
on Empire and there are many people who
are concerned that America has an empire
and doesn't know what to do about it
I wondered if you have any sense by the
way might as a non historian my
impression is that Roosevelt was opposed
to empires like the British Empire he
insisted on dismantling it I believe and
Eisenhower was also not in favor of
empires I wonder if you have any sense
of Kennedy's view of empires both
foreign empires and the possibility that
America was building an empire well
Kennedy was also quite uncomfortable
with these empires and if you remember
what he did in the 1950s he was very
critical of French behavior in Algeria
and thought that they were making a
terrible mistake in trying to hang on to
that colony and he was also highly
critical of their behavior in Vietnam
because his attitude was that if you're
going to save Vietnam it's got to have
autonomy it cannot continue to be
feel that it is under the Frances
control as part of the French Empire and
he kept emphasizing this idea that the
colonialism had passed its day this was
nerve well yes and and and I think he
was uncomfortable with that and and of
course he got into terrible trouble over
Cuba because instantly what the Bay of
Pigs did was the echo American Empire of
echo American sort of imperialism in the
Western Hemisphere and that's why I say
what's striking to me is in the last few
months of his term
when these back-channel conversations
are going on in which they're talking
about a possible reproach mount with
Cuba this is part of I think what he
understands that he is really barking up
a the wrong tree also let me add there's
a lot of controversy as to whether in
fact he knew that assassination plots
were being hatched against Castro would
I say in the book and what I would argue
is that he is the chief executive
whether he knew directly or not he's the
responsible party and if his
administration CIA or whatever agency it
was was plotting these assassinations
then he has to bear a responsibility but
he understood that in many ways empire
had passed its point of of usefulness he
was a very pragmatic man and he
described himself once as an idealist
without illusions and I
got in this case of Empire that's where
he stood I would run look we've almost
run out of time and I think the interest
that bob is stirred by his opening
remarks and by the book here is
indicated by the fact that there are
still questionnaires in the aisle and
I'm so sorry that we can't find time for
you I do want to thank all of you here
in the audience for for coming Bob I've
admired your earlier books I think this
is your finest book and I think that
that one of the many things that your
book will achieve is to stimulate an
interest in Americans to come to this
splendid library and anybody who has not
been here to have seen the wonderful
Museum and the setting here of the sail
boats of bobbing in the in the bay are
missing something I want to give you a
chance we have a minute more to make a
final comment I would simply like to say
that I'm grateful to bill for coming
here today it was really a very nice
thing for him to do and very generous
I'm grateful to the library for for
having me and for arranging this and I'm
grateful to my wonderful supporters that
little brown Jeff Chandler the editor of
my book Claire McKinney who has been
putting up with my constant chatter on
these car rides around New York and now
Boston and the she's going to have to
hear more of me in the future be ad
nauseam but everybody at little brown
has been so supportive of this book and
it's been so gratifying
and seems to be even appealing to a
general public so no complaints
we all wish you well on it
Robert Dalek is author of two
biographies of Lyndon Johnson Lone Star
rising and flawed giant his latest an
unfinished life John F Kennedy 1917 to
1963 is published by Little Brown and
company visit TW bookmark com for more
information